hello welcome to our talk addressing
advanced use cases with new cloud
functions capabilities
i'm vinod i'm a product manager at
google
hi i'm sarah and i'm a cloud developer
advocate at google
here's the overview of our talk first
we'll provide your product overview on
cloud functions then walk you through
key faz and function as a service use
cases
then walk you through the fast
programming model
then we'll cover key performance
scalability and availability features
and cloud functions
then walk you through key new security
features in cloud functions
as well as cover the cloud event support
that is being added to cloud functions
as well
and to conclude we'll cover a couple of
exciting demos provided to you by sarah
so let's get started
cloud functions
cloud functions is google cloud's event
driven serverless compute platform
cloud functions that you write small
snippets of code that react to events
such as http as well as asynchronous
events for example uploading a file to a
cloud storage bucket and doing some
processing after that or sending a
message to pubsub and processing the
message accordingly
cloud functions are truly serverless
they scale seamlessly you don't have to
manage any of the infrastructure and you
pay for what you use
further functions have a streamlined
development model where you can get
started very quickly and have it running
as well
in addition functions are integrated
with different gcp products through
events as well as http
key fast use cases that customers and
users use cloud functions are
servless web hooks
for example pushing uh doing a github
push commit
and then processing a function
uh and posting a message to slack
a real-time data processing where you
can upload files to a cloud storage
bucket and process the data
using mla apis and store the result back
iot back-ends where temperature and
humidity sensors from all over the world
upload temperature and humidity data
data it is processed by cloud functions
and you take corrective action
accordingly
intelligent applications such as twilio
chat bots that upload messages to cloud
functions which are processed by a
natural language api or bigquery for
trend analysis
functions in the fast programming model
are very easily deployable you can
deploy a function from the ui
from the cli
to the ide using functions frameworks as
well as the api
here's a simple example where you have a
snippet of code uh where you can be
deployed using a single command ready to
serve traffic in minutes
you can deploy these functions in your
favorite programming language we are
super excited to ship these languages to
you think about node python go java.net
ruby and php
along with the programming model
functions offer key performance
scalability and availability
capabilities
we are super excited to ship the main
instances capability in cloud functions
call starts is a real problem in
serverless where whenever your function
starts up or your serverless service
starts up your startup tax min instances
lets you mitigate this problem which are
pre-bound instances so for example in
this podcast transcription application
you can have a set of preformed
instances with each of your functions
in order to improve end-to-end latency
of your serverless workflow
here is a github tutorial as well please
feel free to check it out
longer processing we're super excited to
ship longer processing with cloud
functions now you can process your
functions up to 60 minutes this
capability is in preview this is 6x the
execution time
think about longer data processing
pipelines and longer ml pipelines
along with longer processing we are also
shipping larger instances of cloud
functions now you can have up to 16 gb
of memory which is in preview as well as
the ability to have multiple cpus so
think about larger in-memory operations
as well as like embarrassingly parallel
applications with your functions
we've also expanded the number of
regions that are available with cloud
functions going to about 22 regions
globally
along with the other capabilities we
talked about we're adding some new
security capabilities in cloud functions
we're super excited to ship the
integration with secrets manager for
your cloud functions
now you can you know securely set your
environment variables and access them
using secret manager in your cloud
functions in a programmatic fashion and
making the developer experience seamless
as well
along with secrets we are also shipping
a capability called customer managed
encryption keys so
users can provide user provider
encryption keys which can then be used
by gcp to do all the encryption
throughout the function flow
this gives more control to the users and
greater level of encryption as well
and if the key does not work
google cannot even access the data and
it's completely in the control of the
user
shared vpc support we're also super
excited to ship this new networking
capability which lets you your functions
access resources in a shared vpc you can
access compute engine resources as well
as on-prem systems
further this is within a secure vpc sc
parameter which is a logical boundary
that adds additional restrictions such
as only authorized users can deploy to a
deploy a cloud function within the
parameter as well as only authorized
users within the parameter can invoke a
function further the function can be
configured behind a cloud load balancer
for load balancing as well
in addition to the networking
capabilities we are also shipping a
capability called private pools that
gives users more control on their build
time environment for their cloud
function
users can have more control on how their
cloud function is built thereby letting
users control the entire software supply
chain of code build and invocations per
run
along with security capabilities we are
adding cloud event support to cloud
functions as well
cloud events are industry standard
events which are open and portable
making your architecture
for the long term as well
we're adding cloud
cloud event support for cloud functions
by supporting cloud audit logs
this lets you invoke
functions from over 90 plus gcp products
for example every time you create a
compute engine or a vm instance you can
now invoke a function to do some
processing after the vm creation such as
labeling the vm every time a bigquery
job finishes you can do some processing
after the job is completed the same
applies for sql spanner so on and so
forth
now uh i would like to hand over to
sarah who has a couple of interesting
and exciting demos for you on these
capabilities
thanks renee
in the first demo you'll see how you can
use mint instances
to keep a certain number of your
applications warm to
improve performance time
and minimize close starts and the reason
uh why you might want to do this is if
for example you know you're going to be
receiving additional traffic soon
perhaps it's due to like a black friday
cyber monday event or you know that you
just you need to get the best possible
vacancy time so by keeping um a certain
number of instances warm you can help um
reduce coast starts and get the best uh
latency and the uh
response time possible so you'll see how
that uh works in uh this upcoming demo
in this first demo i have a nodejs
function and it's already deployed when
min instance is set to zero which is the
default so let's take a look at this
function code
now the entry point is hello world so
that means that all the code outside of
the entry point is going to be in global
scope so in other words here is the
event handler the entry point for the
function so any code outside of that
function like here
as you see is in global scope
so this uh so line three
where we uh
call the startup method
this is going to get uh executed anytime
there is a cold start like the instance
is uh warming up so we'll log
that this is a cold start and then
you'll see me
simulate a long connection this could be
something to i call to establish in
connection with the database this could
be a an api call that takes a while to
uh respond but something that you want
to do
once cache a value and have it um
available for future invocations of your
function
and so once
the this time out to sleep it comes back
then
you'll see me log on i'm ready now and
then return uh ready back
so here is the code that is invoked
every time that is executed every time
the function is a vote and i'm using
utility for just pure debugging purposes
just to illustrate what is happening
and it's getting the uh
the current status of the of the
and if it's still a cold start it
reports that it waits until
the
30 second timeout has completed and then
says now i'm warmed up using the warm
emoji
otherwise if it's already a warm
instance then it just uh reports back
that it's a warm instance and of course
it needs to respond back to the requests
with uh requests completed
so let's
invoke our function and see this in
action
so on the trigger
we'll see if we click here
and this is going to take uh because of
the 30 seconds
so we can go to
cloud logging
and
as that is spinning up we'll see it
report
as we saw in the code
i am a cold start
that will be logged first
okay so there it is i'm a cold start
i'm still cold start so if we go back
here we'll see i'm a cold start
and since we invoked it while it was
still appending
that's where we see this and then as
soon as it comes back it'll say i'm
warmed up okay we see that the request
completed and we'll see in the logs
okay the function is completed so now
i am warmed up
which is great but
but let's say like we know in advance
we're going to get future
invocations what can we do
to you might be thinking what can i do
to
have this ready to go maybe this
connection uh database connection
already excelish or
uh like this api call like have that
value
already cached ready to go when there is
when you can predict that you're going
to have future implications and that's
where min instances come comes in
so now you'll see me
redeploy the function using the
instances so let's go to edit
and then
in these advanced features
scroll down you'll see min instances
and instead of using zero let's give it
five
and deploy that
now that this function has been deployed
with
the new um instances i can go here and
see
in details now that we have five min
instances we can confirm that if we go
to the logs now
and rerun this query
you'll see the cloud function is updated
and you might
think that this is off by one but
instead of five cold starts because
remember very spinning up five instances
you might be thinking well why am i
seeing six well this first one is called
a health check this is just to make sure
that your cloud function builds and as a
part of it not invo not being invoked
but just builds and since
this is in global scope that's going to
get executed
and that so but this is just a health
check just to make sure that like the
coding correct like that you're um there
wasn't like a compile error or build
error or there was like a missing
dependency or like the function um
identity black permissions that's what
uh this health check is so that's why
you see uh six of these
and now if we were to go
we'll go back to the to the function go
back to trigger
and see no you notice that it hit
instantly
and if we go to cloud run that we've got
sorry okay run query
really see that
after the like
all the uh instances were warm and you
see i'm a warm
instance so as you just saw
you might want to consider using mint
instances to keep a certain number of
your uh cloud your cloud functions uh
instances warm in case you're expecting
an increase in traffic or you just need
to get the best latency times uh
possible
now for the second uh demo you're going
to see how a cloud function can listen
uh for and respond to a cloud audit log
event
for example let's say that a company has
a policy where their engineers
need to put their
username as a label on any vm that they
create well you can have a checklist for
your for their engineers to to follow
but they might forget or they might have
a typo and so one of the
best ways to
reduce human error is to quote automate
it out
so
instead you could write a cloud function
to listen to a cloud audit log event for
whenever a vm is created and have the
cloud function automatically label
the vm with their username instead
in this second demo you'll see how you
can use a cloud function to listen for
and respond to a cloud audit log event
in this scenario you'll see a cloud
function automatically label a vm using
the username of the person who created
it
so first let's go over how to deploy a
function to respond to a cloud audit log
event now notice in this deployment
you'll specify the trigger event filters
so we have of type cloud arctic log
service name is compute
and insert
instance is when a new instance is
created
so let's deploy that
and while that deploys let's take a look
at the code
so the first thing to notice is that the
uh the signature for the uh the for the
for the function event handlers is
different and now is quality event and
so we grab the data from the cloud event
uh data payload
and just in case an event has more than
one audit log we want to make sure we're
responding to the very last event
the resource names
they kind of they
they
look like this in this particular case
and so we want to break it up and grab
the instance name and the username
and we log appropriately
now uh if you're trying to
like in this case set
a label
the
api make sure that you're setting the
most recent label and so you need to
get the
the instance label
fingerprint
otherwise you're not going to be able to
set the label
and then we can invoke the
vm label
and then finally we log the results
so let's look at the set vm label it's
on the more interesting of the two
so here's the api call we saw it we set
up instance name zone project resource
here i have the label named as creator
and then you'll see my username for this
account and then we make the api call to
set the label for the instance
okay
now let's uh take a peek
and yes our uh
club function has finished deploying so
let's jump over
to cloud console and if we refresh
we'll see
the vmware demo is up
let's go to the vms create a new vm
we'll just use the defaults
and as soon as that is created you'll
see the
the label uh is added and the nice thing
about having a cloud function
automatically perform this task is one
lesson that you have to ask your
engineers or your developers or whoever
is doing a particular task it's one less
thing for them to remember to do so
instead of having like a long check
checklist like did i do this did i do
that the more you can automate that out
the less human error you will have
so let's go to the instance
and now you can see that the creator is
the rough eras which is my username or
my full names therefore it's spelled
backwards for my demo account purposes
thank you sarah for those amazing and
exciting demos
so that's all i have folks with our
session on cloud functions
please check out cloud functions at
cloud.google.com stroke functions
please also sign up for the advanced
features that we have covered in this
session you can do so by reaching out to
us
further if you have any questions please
feel free to reach out to us as well
thank you and have a great conference
you